[Musique]
le letchi à la réunion c'est plus de 700
hectares de plantations pour près de 200
producteurs
si la récolte 2016 a été exceptionnel
avec 8000 tonnes de production l'année
2010 est a par contre été catastrophique
avec seulement 1600 tonnes soit une
perte nette de 80 %
pour répondre à cette crise et soutenir
les exploitants agricoles le département
met à disposition des planteurs une aide
exceptionnelle lors d'un costume
commission permanente du 6 décembre
dernier nous avons pris la décision
d'accorder une aide à la préparation des
vergers pour cette année 2010 8 de
l'ordre de 2000 euros ha la crise que
connaît les chier exceptionnel cette
aide est déjà opérationnel elle
s'applique aux agriculteurs déclarant
des surfaces en vergers de letchis à la
cgss pour 2017 et qui affiche une perte
de revenu supérieure à 30% du
prévisionnel le montant forfaitaire de
2000 euros par hectare vise à améliorer
l'entretien des vergers
ce qui est important c'est vrai c'est
que l'on puisse me défends du coup pour
qu'ils puissent entretenir leurs vergers
donc réaliser de la taille réalisée du
coût des apports fertilisants donc si
pingre et c'est important aussi du coup
qu'ils à un fonds de roulement un peu
pour acheter je sais pas - du matériel
agricole pour entretenir leurs parcelles
oui effectivement ça sera un levier pour
qu'ils leur permettront sûrement si les
conditions le permettent d'avoir une
bonne récolte l'année prochaine
les agriculteurs ont jusqu'à fin juin
pour nous retourner le dossier complet
le formulaire rempli mais on va pas
attendre le dernier dossier dès qu'un
agriculteur aura déposé son dossier
contrôlé par la chambre d'agriculture
nous aurons la rapidité suffisante pour
verser cette aide à la remise en état
des berges et le département de la
réunion en charge de la politique
agricole sur le territoire met en place
des leviers économiques pour soutenir et
accompagner la modernisation des
exploitations agricoles
[Musique]